bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france c'était une
action concertée avec vos collègues
communistes et écologistes hier soir
n'ont même pas mais ce n'est pas
nécessaire ça l'a fait des mois que
comme les députés français smithzz je
revendique la démission du préfet
l'allemand parce qu'il faut bien avoir
conscience que la conduite par le préfet
rendement des opérations dites de
maintien de l'ordre sont en fait une
stratégie d' escalade de la violence et
à coût de l bd à coups de grenades de
désencerclement de gaz lacrymogène
d'action extrêmement violente
qu'il s'agisse des de la période des
manifestations gilet jaune des
mobilisations contre les retraites ou la
contre la loi sécurité globale et bien
ce préfet ne garantit pas le droit de
manifester mais au contraire le remis en
cause et ce week-end franchement les
années station abusives ont à nouveau
montré que sa volonté c'est à la fois de
dissuader les manifestants de manifester
et en même temps de faire de la
propagande c'est leur faire croire
qu'ils arrêtent les casseurs les black
blocks alors qu'on a des personnes qui
n'avaient rien à se reprocher qui tout
simplement manifestaient donc ça suffit
puis à plein d'autres reproches que nous
faisons au préfet l'allemand sa chasse
des sans papiers après le démantèlement
du camp de saint denis et de la place de
la république
et puis son inaction face aux problèmes
de racisme systémique dans la police et
les violences policières comme on a pu
voir sur le terrible épisode du
commissariat du 17e alors comment s'est
terminé la séance hier soir le budget de
la préfecture de police a été votée ou
pas oui il a finalement été votée mais
bon j'ai voté contre le groupe
communiste le groupe europe ecologie les
verts générations ont voté contre
également et donc je regrette que
d'ailleurs madame hidalgo qui n'a pas eu
un seul mot de critiques contre la loi
sécurité globale et qui amène l'essai
sur un passage médias sous-entendre
qu'elle soutenait l'article 24
elle veut tellement sa police municipale
qu'elle ne critique pas eh bien ni le la
stratégie du préfet l'allemand ni la
politique de monsieur darmanin en la
matière anne hidalgo la maire de paris
qui a donc en partie des fonds du didier
lallement pointant plutôt la
responsabilité de gérald darmanin son
ministre de tutelle elle je considère
que les responsables politiques n'ont
pas à s'attaquer aux fonctionnaires
c'est ce qu'elle a déclaré
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces propos
écoutez monsieur le préfet l'allemand
n'est pas juste un fonctionnaire on sait
pertinemment
qu'il a été installé sur paris parce
qu'il avait déjà montré de quoi il était
capable en gironde
rappelez-vous en gironde il avait y
compris assumer que ses forces pour que
la police s'attaque également un député
dépité de la france est soumise
donc non je dire on voit que madame
hidalgo à une stratégie politique qui
n'est pas d'incarner une opposition face
à macro premièrement et qui finalement
est bien accepte l'orientation politique
qui est menée actuellement par le
gouvernement sur ces thématiques de
sécurité et j'en veux pour preuve
comment elle s'auto félicite que le
gouvernement lui permettre de pouvoir
mettre en place sa police municipale
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
revoit de fond en comble la police
nationale pour ce qu'il ya vraiment une
refonte de la police qu'on arrête la
stratégie du chiffre qu'on mette en
place des récépissés contre le contrôle
au faciès qu'on permette à la police de
faire vraiment un travail d enquête sur
le terrain qu'on retrouve une police de
proximité
et ça c'est essentiel or on sait que
toutes les villes qui mettent en place
des polices municipales
la première conséquence quand on
abandonne cette fonction régalienne
c'est que les élus les gouvernements
successifs ont réduit les effectifs de
police pour les municipalités combinant
place des polices municipales
merci d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne ce
soir danielle simonnet conseillère de
paris oratrice de la france en soumises